their speed run i'll give you a name
give me one word that comes to your mind
steve bannon
uh
[Music]
[Laughter]
idiot okay corey londowski
a small man hope hicks
good person
roger stone
good friend kellyanne conway
good friend mike pence
uh a very good vice president desantis
uh the potential future
mueller
uh a man who's passed
one word
not a good person there's not one word
but mueller was used
and
in my book i talk about my experience
with him
i was not impressed with him hillary
clinton
fake
biden
uh
[Music]
over beyond his time the fbi
uh
i don't want to define all of their
people who abuse their power avenatti
uh
charlotte
cohen michael cohen
uh over set podesta
which one
uh
the one you worked with good guy okay
uh john durham
uh
hope
last but not least donald trump
uh
a man who made a difference
fantastic awesome so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]
you